foreign
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us in a
session
of optimizing kubernetes particularly
not just optimizing it for cost
efficiency but for reliability which is
one of the key pieces that we want to
talk about through this session
joining me myself I am Ken Hua I am a
global solution manager focused on gke
and app modernization for optimization
and joining me is Chris mear from
Priceline as well as Thomas Evans from
cubecast
so they will come on and talk about some
of their pieces and we'll kind of run
through that we will take some questions
at the end and possibly some post
session as well if you have any
questions afterwards
so I will get right to it from a topic
perspective I mentioned the presenters
Chris and both Thomas but I'll cover the
research so for those of us that are may
or may not be familiar some of us may
have caught it late June from a Google
perspective we released a report to kind
of focus on optimization of kubernetes
in the context of cost efficiency as
well as reliability and one of the key
pieces when we talk about the report is
focusing on cloud agnostic so albeit
here I'm speaking from a Google Cloud
perspective the report itself is cloud
agnostic so albeit from this perspective
as I mentioned I'll cover some Google
kubernetes engine aspects as well
so with that in mind is as part of the
report we went through a methodology of
how do we classify for those of us that
may have been familiar with the state of
devops report in the previous years they
had some level of classification of how
they segmented some of their
participants in this case our
participants were anonymized gke
clusters and this fleet was less than or
equal to three nodes we didn't want the
smaller ones we wanted some of the
larger ones as well to kind of mix and
match the overall construct of how we
segmented
we used the construct of classification
tree to help us segment this as well as
give us some little semblance of
opinionation which you'll notice on the
bottom right hand corner is the at-risk
section and that's when we talk about
that reliability element of it is where
does that play into all of this we did a
quasi interval as I mentioned earlier we
have segments of elite high medium low
as well as the at-risk potion and funny
enough so we actually took this data
grouping for January 2023. one would
think that oh we actually first took
this of November 2022 and for those of
us in certain sectors November of 2022
is very critical to our business and we
kind of use that as a measuring so
looking through it we noticed that the
data didn't actually change very much
overall the story kind of told itself
equally overall so we chose Johnny 2023
as the data set
I mean kind of walk through that if we
look at the report as a whole some of us
may have caught the blog post one of the
key things outside of the report that
we're talking about is to have a minimum
set of reliability for workloads that
require not all workloads require a
sense of reliability but if workloads do
have that minimum sense of reliability
the least thing we can do out of this
entire session at least for my part is
set resource requests on your workloads
so for those of us familiar with
kubernetes we know this is a construct
that we can use in order to reserve
certain resources within a node of a
cluster
the reason why we want to set resource
requests albeit reserving is that it has
a lot of critical things that it
controls or augments with it excuse me
within our cluster
when we think about standard resource
requests we think about I'm just
reserving resources but in reality we
can see here a list of different things
that can be augmented tweaked impacted
as a result of not setting requests on
our workloads so that's a very critical
thing we think about if we're looking at
Auto scaling for our nodes because
that's how kubernetes usually triggers
it I schedule more pods they're in
pending mode if my cluster Auto scaler
is enabled and I have more resources
available to me it will scale up but if
I don't set request it will just keep
throwing it on similar nodes without
understanding because that's how
kubernetes schedules by using requests
and this is sort of that critical
element if we look at it from this
particular use case I said throw a bunch
of pods in a particular node
this would actually potentially scale up
if I hit my 110 pod limit if that's my
maximum pods per node if I set that up
so that is one mechanism I can use to
help me drive that behavior but all I
have to do really is set requests and
we'll talk about that a little further
as well
as part of the report I mentioned some
opinionation a lot of that opinionation
is driven across what we've discussed
with customers as yourselves as well as
organizations to say what is important
because we know kubernetes can emit a
lot of metrics but how do we get some
semblance of understanding and these are
what we see as the golden signals from
left to right is workload right sizing
am I asking for enough and of what I'm
actually meeting within my workload
am I using too little am I using too
much how do I right size that
How about if at non-peak depending on
the industries that we represent or work
through we have different off-peak times
and if there are off big times we'd like
to scale down to reduce our consumption
of resources because there's no demand
so how do we set that and how do we
measure that
the next piece is a lot of what we see
in this room we talk about cluster bin
packing this room is fairly been packed
and what happened was essentially we
can't vertically scale this room anymore
so we scaled horizontally we have a
session on Thursday so that's another
way of viewing it from a bin packing
perspective we're fairly packed in this
room right now and how do we measure
that because I want to make the use of
the machines that I provision
the last piece is how I adopt Cloud
discounts and Cloud discounts come in
the form of spot type of VMS or
discounts that are available in this
case through Google Cloud committed use
discounts that I can apply and this is
something where Chris will actually come
on and tell how Priceline did it from
their perspective because I have
multiple strategies that I can apply
when I talk through discounting and go
through that but these are the signals
that we're measuring we added one more
metric which was essentially which
workloads are not sending requests in
how we segmented our clusters
so as a result if you hadn't had a
chance to catch the report there are
seven findings that we kind of alluded
to or ran through and the first piece is
setting requests
by not I unders by understanding setting
the amount of report resource requests
for the workloads that have a minimum
reliability notice that I said minimum
reliability because there are some
workloads that qualify that I want to be
best effort but there are also some
impacts if they are best effort so
that's something that's the most
critical thing as I mentioned that was
that third slide that I had in the
presentation
the second piece I showed four signals
across workload right sizing down scale
bin packing discounts workload right
sizing is actually the most critical one
because if you think about it if my
workloads are not right size properly
I can impact how I scale potentially how
I
bin pack because I might not pick the
right machine because kubernetes is
going to say what machines do I need and
if my applications say I lean a lot more
than I actually need from an
application's perspective I may look
like I've been packing very well but in
reality I may not be contacting as well
as I'd want
and and the fourth one is you send third
one is essentially being able to if I
over exert an index on cost efficiency I
can impact my reliability
for instance I start bringing down
certain resources I can impact the
reliability of my workloads because I'm
getting too aggressive in how I tear
down particular pods or tear down
particular nodes
the fourth one is I just spoke to you
about pods and nodes and all this
technical stuff from a kubernetes
perspective but when we are performing
these actions within our clusters there
is real life potential end user
experience that may be impacted as a
result because we think about it
workloads are coming through if I need
to scale up it takes time before I can
actually serve a request that comes
through if I'm bringing down a workload
what about that transaction that's in
flight so those are things that can
impact my end user experience so that's
the fourth key finding
when we look at the fifth one is all
about yes I mentioned demand-based down
scaling is a metric but how about the
impact of it we want it to be automated
we don't want to be involved as part of
this downscaling mechanism so we need to
use constructs that are available to us
Within kubernetes
horizontal pod Auto scalar which helps
us go wider is one mechanism to
elastically grow as well as shrink
without us being involved otherwise we
on the operations side developer side
have to determine what are my Max my
minimums and I'm going out through my
pipeline to adjust these sizes that may
not be the most quickest reaction we
want the let's cluster perform for us if
our workloads allow us to do such
the sixth one is about Elite and high
performance they do take advantage of
cloud discounts and what we usually see
when we talk about these clusters and
the segments usually the Clusters that
are larger we pay a lot of attention to
these clusters and they we have more
visibility as again Crystal kind of run
through being aware of what our
workloads require gives us a more sense
of confidence when we want to say I can
commit to these certain amount of
resources for my one year to three year
perspective depending on our level of
confidence
the last one it depends on the tooling
we use because a lot of tools that are
out there very much focused on
allocation of cost is based on or equal
to the request that I set
so on that third slide when I said set
requests if I'm not sending requests
potentially those costs are not
accounted for and that's something that
we need to address KU class does a
little differently they take Max use or
and or respect requests so that's one
way to look at it as well but we just
need to be cognizant if we're using
third-party tools or other tools what is
being factored in as far as what is an
actual request
it's very interesting we see I can read
numbers but in reality when we look at
it
for elite and performers over low
performers they get more value they get
more for what they pay for and they
heavily utilize discounts because
they're aware of what's happening when I
contacts or construct when I said they
these are clusters we don't have any
groupings of these segments or anything
these are just clusters that seem to
exhibit these behaviors but in reality
when we look at it they are getting more
use of what they have which typically
means that utilization is probably
higher right sizing is a little bit
better or better awareness of the right
sizing and if my right sizing is just
right
because there is no magic to it I just
don't apply a number I need to
understand these on a per workload basis
that I can then confidently determine
what should my discounts be as a result
of that
going back to this last segment that I
said we carved out for not only is it
that if I my cost allocations impacted
the reliability could be impacted is
that negative user experience that could
potentially happen because we think
about it is when a node gets to its
limit
if it's a best effort workload which is
a workload does not set request it's
unfortunately the first to go when the
kublet needs to protect itself
so it has a starvation mechanism that
says
I have no more resources who's the first
to go best effort then burstable
guaranteed is that one that I reserve
resources but things can still happen
but we can see a tier of how the kublet
reacts as a result of this
and we see this a lot for instance some
of our workloads exhibit that 1.6 x
times more
so this is something from a best ever
perspective what is that impact to my
workload and the last one we talk about
is best effort is sending requests but
what about the burstable ones so this is
under provisioned memory memory is
something that with CPU I can throttle
albeit can impact user experience memory
is fairly static once that memory is
consumed or allocated for I can't really
reallocate it unless that pod goes down
so that's something that can impact our
end user experience as a result of that
the at-risk segment also has some sense
of I want to optimize so potentially
when we look at the address segment
could potentially be over indexing on
that low hanging fruit we think of cloud
discounts because I can think about it
from the perspective of I want to save
money I should just commit to a certain
amount of resources which could be
helpful but remember remember that is
the last part if I resize and actually
properly workload right size I may now
be heavily over provisioned for what I
committed for but that's something to
think about when we talk about the
address segment
this kind of gets into that construct of
do I have enough data for what I want to
work with and that's that insufficient
data I saw how much my current cluster
is using I'm going to commit to that and
then I actually perform some right
sizing activities and maybe I possibly
could have over committed so those are
things where we talk about workload
right sizing key finding number two
becomes that very critical element when
I drive towards that
this kind of all we also look at this
from a utilization perspective if I
don't send requests my bin packing is
low so think about this if my bin
packing shows that I'm 50 bin packed I
go I could probably do less with 25 of
my nodes
so I bring down those 25 of nodes but
because my requests I didn't ask for it
all of those are now consuming more
resources I actually don't have room
it's almost like at 50 bin packing I am
masking what's happening within my
environment I'm throwing more nodes at
it in order to prevent the reliability
thing I'm trying to prevent
so that's something we think about as
well if we over provision our nodes that
can kind of hide some things that we're
lacking within our environment and I
bring it down I tear it down I bring it
on 25 I don't want to go too crazy by
doing 50 let's do 25 but what happens to
that overhead I no longer have that
wiggle room so I think I'm doing and all
of a sudden I think I'm doing better in
bin packing but in reality my workloads
are at risk as a result of it
so from a Google Cloud perspective so
those of us may be familiar with that
optimization tab that's made Available
to You metrics that are made available
to recommendations so from a Google
Cloud perspective even if I have vpa
recommendation or I don't deploy vpa
within my cluster we're actually
Gathering some of those metrics for us
behind the scenes as a metric so that's
something that you can leverage that
we've kind of utilized in our dashboards
to help you understand
at a high level
now we don't understand from an
optimization tap perspective that is
something that we see per cluster which
first if I have three clusters and a
handful of clusters that's really easy
to see
but we've also released dashboards to
help you see at a higher level at an
organizational level so there are tools
that we applied and can we deploy that
and be able to maximize how we look at
those resources
we also have workshops and
recommendations that are provided
workshops that Priceline went through so
these are things that we kind of go
through to say proactively in a
data-driven way how is my environment
what is my current health so this is
something if you're currently using
kubernetes engine today you can ask of
your account team that we want to assess
the health of our workloads and our
clusters and go through that process
the other pieces I talked about sending
requests I talk about all these
mechanisms to protect my workload what
are ways to potentially enforce that so
if we're not familiar with autopilot
autopilot automatically sets requests
for us whether we like it or not and we
actually are forced to go back and
re-evaluate what my requests are because
it will set its minimum and either my
workload is not going to work or I need
to adjust that minimum because it's over
provisioned so we kind of set forth that
particular element another thing that
we've just launched in preview is a
constant policy bundle for reliability
and being able to use this along with
policycontroller Opa gatekeeper from an
open source perspective but also a
bundle to help you enforce setting
requests
setting labels on our workloads I didn't
speak any about this but labels are very
helpful for our workloads in order for
us to categorize
but also setting pod disruption budgets
standing requests enforcing that Upon
Our workloads and within our pipeline so
there's a lot of things that from a
Google Cloud perspective we can kind of
help you with if you're taking advantage
of it and those are available
so that's at a high level for the report
as well as gke and kind of running
through that and with that I will hand
it over to Chris and he'll cover what
Priceline did for the workshop as well
as what they've taken further so thanks
Chris
awesome thanks Kent appreciate that
hey everybody hope everybody's having a
great next
all right let's jump right into it
so Priceline is uh online travel agency
underneath of booking Holdings
Incorporated we've been an industry
leader for about 25 years and over the
last few years we've embarked on a cloud
Journey that cloud Journey has been
driven mainly by a cultural shift and
you've probably heard this story before
how do we shift our our teams from
thinking around the data center to
thinking around cloud
so in supporting that we had this
massive shift within a few short years
what supported that was our
infrastructure is code and terraforming
and you'll see the foundations inside
the triangle here
our fin Ops approach our modernization
of our self-service approach for our
development teams through an updated
modern pipeline that allowed us to ship
those workloads into kubernetes and
we'll talk more about that but prior to
that being able to ship your workload
required us to have a 12 factor for
those applications to make them
resilient and and really be able to be
managed by kubernetes
so here's a few topics we're going to
dive into
um
we'll talk about requests which Kent
talked about extremely important the
discounts we leveraged to try and make
this efficient and cost effective the
bin packing we use to reduce those idle
costs and the right sizing the important
right sizing of those applications to
tailor them to what the application
required and make it efficient in terms
of what it's consuming inside of cloud
lastly I'll talk about traffic egress
traffic and scale down how do we scale
these things down as well as scale them
up and scale them down effectively
all right so requests right Cannon plus
size this enough the reservation of
resource for your container how do I
make sure my containers are effective in
serving the applications that are
running on them is by setting that
minimum request what is the minimum
required amount of resource for that
application to serve effectively to my
end users
um those resources now are available for
your container and gke will manage those
containers as well as the pods they
reside on those pods will move
throughout gke by process of it's
creating an efficient use of the
consumption of those nodes so those pods
can be fluid right and the key point
there is as those things move you want
to make sure that request is there to
guarantee to Ken's point that that
minimum amount of resources available
for your app to keep that app performant
so for Priceline we needed to make sure
that those CPU and member quests were
gated in our pipelines to ensure that as
teams are onboarding and migrating into
kubernetes that they would have those
data requests already defined
next thing I want to talk about is
discounts so standard use discount or
sud is a discount that you really get by
proxy of consuming a resource for a
period of a month so it's kind of
already there for you you don't really
need to do anything other than consume
those resources and that's for on-demand
resources committed use discounts these
are things that need to be strategically
invested with them right so for
priceline's approach what we did was we
teamed up across teams communicating
with our SRE teams our program
management teams our application teams
about what's happening in our
environment what applications are being
migrated what applications are expected
to grow
what do we see as different compute
types that we want to consume what's
happening across regions so all of these
elements are key elements to consider
when you're thinking about how to invest
why is that well I'll do a little segue
about committed use discounts standard
versus Flex standard committed use
discounts are Regional compute based
discounts so if you invest on a
particular compute type within a
particular region that's where that
investment will reside it cannot be
ported to another region or a different
compute type so that's why you need to
be specific about that
that team up about what's happening in
the environment would then generate a
report for us to say here's what we
think is happening over the next six to
12 and 36 months and how do we plan on
investing to support that our investment
strategy has been Target 80 percent
coverage that'll give us flexibility for
eventualities in that period of time
because this is a commitment in a
committed use discount for one or three
years
we also staggered our investments so as
we consume expirations happen over the
course of the year which also provides
additional flexibility so when you
consume in thousands of cores when you
have a significant shift you can pivot
with that
there's discounts all right next slide
all right let's talk about uh Bin
packing right so cluster Auto scaler
um is a fantastic feature in kubernetes
right which allows as Ken said the node
to expand with consumption or scale down
so scaling up and scaling down this
essentially packs those pods in based on
what the requests are for your
containers so the key here for us was to
get a communication across our
organization to trust in the process in
cluster Auto scalar based on the fact
that your apps have been 12 factored say
we'll be resilient and based on the fact
that you've set requests for a minimum
performance on your applications so
trust in the process we engaged
initially in the balanced profile which
is essentially the default profile and
it's a safer profile it does not it's
not as aggressive as the optimized
utilization profile the optimize
utilization profile was what we later
followed on with and as that's more
aggressive it's going to give you a much
more larger reduction in your idle costs
but it will also create this situation
where it takes a little longer to spin
up your pods right so because it's so
aggressively downsized there's no extra
idle resource for you to spin up quickly
so how do we deal with that well we use
what was called pod pause pods to set
additional reservations to allow us to
spin those things up quicker
right so all of those efforts really
we've seen up to 60 percent reduction in
those idle costs which was amazing for
us
all right so right sizing there's a
couple slides on this one and I broke it
up into two sections because I think the
organizational piece of this is really
important how should our teams tune what
is required safely and efficiently
communication is the most valuable tool
you're going to have in your tool belt
here so you want to identify and agree
on what the high value targets are so
high yield low effort is the key
you also want to set up guidelines and
guard rails in documentation reviews
that's easily consumed and easily
actionable
additionally what we also did was we
leveraged what we call our architecture
Guild where teams participate in open
Communications about how to consider
what their app consumes how to consider
what happens in zones or regions this
open conversation allowed teams to air
out their concerns whether they could
consume what guard rails or guidelines
were there and allowed us to Pivot on
making those more efficient as well
lastly program managed to be able to
have TPMS across teams participate with
the team in moving that ball from less
efficient to more efficient in right
sizing application and testing through
that sdlc
all right so execution of that right
sizing here's some of the actual tools
we leveraged the first piece was a
dedicated performance operations staff
so our embedded devops team was created
for focus on things like performance and
consumption so how performant is my
application and how do I consider how
efficient my application is so those
teams help focus with our SRE teams to
get those applications fast tracked into
a right sizing process additionally in
our emission controller we use mutating
web hooks to gate what can be deployed
in our non-production environments so as
an application team may have sets of
requests that they want to run at a
certain level and move that through the
sdlc it may not be necessary and the web
hook Gates that so that we're not
deploying in non-production resources
that aren't being consumed
additionally workload aware of
visualization how do we show development
teams what their app is consuming in
Priceline we are an active active
multi-region deployment so I need to
know what my aggregate of consumption is
at any point in time and over a course
of time so that I have a reliable set of
metrics to base my decisions upon
okay into traffic so as a multi-regional
deployment for our runtime we also have
multi-zone right so lots of layers of
resiliency and redundancy there which is
fantastic but it also generates a
concern around egress traffic
it's very easy to consider Regional
egress traffic is the first thing you
think about it's very expensive to have
traffic egress across regions but
additionally interzone traffic is a very
significant expense and needs to be
examined
58 was the the amount that we were able
to hit in reducing our interest Zone and
egress cost which is tremendous we
leveraged uh istio we have as our
service mesh and we leveraged locality
load balancing to keep those traffic
patterns within zones
um topology awareness is another
component we leveraged on top of that so
topology spread constraints how do my
pods deploy inside of my zones set
spread amounts so that you have those
across the zones that you have deployed
lastly reporting how do I see things are
happening with the traffic from a
traffic perspective from a billing
perspective you can go to the billing
console look at skus filter based on
that and see what the interzone egress
costs are what may be spiking across
what projects or what particular
namespaces
lastly you can investigate into that
through things like networking
Intelligence Center and the topology
cooler it's another fantastic tool
all right so uh scaling
a couple slides left before I'll be
turning it over to Thomas to talk about
some of the cube costs and visualize
some of these things but scaling up as
Kent mentioned is very key to a lot of
organizations especially those that are
retail and go through things like Cyber
Monday right so how do I scale up HPA is
a fantastic solution for that it also
scales back down for you so how do we
make sure that we're scaling up and down
safely what metrics do we target is an
effort per application team to look at
their apps and figure out how to Target
which particular metrics
so Target your high value applications
again you want to look for high yield
low effort to get you the quickest
return on your investment of effort
right
additionally partnership with teams so
pulling in your site reliability
Engineers your infrastructure teams and
program management to think about how
we're going to move this from one level
of a static to an HPA
lastly as I mentioned multiple Regional
resiliency we had to think about okay so
if we have Regional maintenance how do
we warm up a site that's running an HPA
because HPA will balance those traffic
loads so that the less hot site I'll
call it that way the warm site has less
traffic than the hot site how do we warm
that up or heat it up so that it's ready
to take traffic so we had to approach
this within the strategy of
pre-warming those pods launching them in
and that's where our SRE team
architecture team were able to create a
Loosely coupled architecture and when
that Google Cloud devops award
all right so we talked a lot about
scaling there with HPA scaling down is
the big trick here though for multiple
zones
scaling down requires effort to optimize
remember that cluster Auto scaler does
scale your nodes up and down but it does
not have topology spread constraint when
it scales down
so we use things like kubernetes 6D
scheduler which reviews how the spread
is existing and it evicts pods and then
the cluster Auto scaler will then
redeploy them according to the topology
spread constraints
so essentially it's evicting what's
overloaded and allows the auto scaler to
bring it back up to parity
all right lastly to sum this all up
folks
Community Based right I mentioned a
number of times teaming up having
multiple teams talking across each other
Communications is the most valuable tool
so that's a key Point high value low
effort another key consideration and
easily consumed actionable guidance goes
right along with communication as a key
all right with that I'll turn it over to
Thomas thanks everybody
yes
good afternoon everyone can you hear me
all right there we go right on so my
name is Thomas Evans I'm the director of
engineering for Cube cost and Chris and
Kent just give you a very technical Deep
dive into something that our products
are going to make really easy for you
really really quickly but before I get
into that let's talk about how Coop cost
came to be
very simply we are a cost optimization
tool that is solely focused on
optimizing your kubernetes spend so
we're going to give you great visibility
we're going to grave you great action
items that you can use to go exercise
your your phenops muscle against your
current kubernetes offering so
our product was built by two former
former googlers Webb Brown and a j
trippa thing who came out of here oh
gosh four or five years ago now and they
quickly realized on the old board
project kubernetes or what was going to
be kubernetes was a very complex problem
right really really good at giving you
flexibility in your workloads giving you
a whole lot of configurability and a
whole lot of opportunity it was really
really bad at letting you see any of the
magic under the hood right particularly
when it came to cost really good at
throwing things in the pool racking up
your bill every single month and you
having no idea where your money went
right really cool
so that's where Kube cost comes into
play we're going to give you a really
clear Solution on how to identify your
costs we're going to allocate them back
do the chargebacks we'll do all sorts of
actionable insights that let you really
go in and exercise your muscles against
these golden signals that Kent and Chris
just talked about so let's talk about
just three right so I think we offer 12
to 15 in the product depending on your
configuration but to start off let's
talk about the resource requests right
the obvious low hanging fruit in the
room
um
Cube costs will provide a page that
allows you to dive in and see which
which workloads
either do not have any sort of resource
requests set to them or which ones are
under or over provisioned right so we've
got a couple of different algorithms and
you've got some options on how you
actually want to calculate those but
we're going to provide recommendations
that say hey you're 40 over provisionary
you really need to go adjust this to
really help your bin packing and your
other side effects from this
looking at leverage demand based down
scaling again Kube cost provides a
couple of items here that lets you go in
and automatically down scale your uh
your workloads as need be based upon
different components throughout it
and then finally discount coverage sad
to say Coupe cost AI can't quite call
Google and negotiate your bill down
we're working on it but for now we'll
stick with reserved instance sizing uh
and spot instances as well and we're
going to go in and be able to identify
some of those workloads that are ready
for you and provide recommendations
based on that
so the fun part about today for anybody
who's familiar with our product it has
to be installed in your kubernetes
cluster in your own cloud however that
is no longer the case Kube cost cloud is
now available it is in general
availability and it's a simple agent
install and we're going to give you
these golden signals in a little under
five minutes so all of that said would
love to bring Canton Chris back up
we'll talk through a couple other
components here so I can
report as far as the couple first couple
slides so this is an opportunity if you
haven't had a chance to download the
report these slides will be available
tomorrow as well in PDF form but the QR
code if you want to download the report
and see in detail what I was able and
the team everyone was able to summarize
and then work through kind of that
process to kind of understand what I
talked through but also what else is
there available for the team to kind of
realize within your organization
and as a part of that are other sessions
that are available related to cost Chris
gets to tell us not today was about gke
he has other sessions to talk about
overall gcp so if you're on gcp the
opportunity how you can look at it from
a cost perspective for all of your gcp
environment but also some other areas
around what's new with kubernetes and in
the Showcase with our demo Booth there's
also some pieces that I believe broadcom
also goes to remember optimization
perspective so other sessions for you to
keep in mind as well beyond the report
and then I believe Coupe cost has
something we do yeah so two things so
please come see us we're at Booth 1650
downstairs we'd love to talk to you and
walk you through some of the finer
details of Kube cost Cloud but today
we're also partnering with thoughtworks
so today at six o'clock over in
thoughtworks is headquarters just across
the street uh we are going to have a
happy hour with them would love to see
you over there would love to talk
through some of these details that we
provide
[Music]
foreign